a falar o tanque é o prazer estar aqui
convosco com anemia é impossível viajar
tem sido muito difícil então tenho uma
dedicado a outra paixão para me levar
além-fronteiras o que é ler e e também
estão a ver viagens e livros têm sido
também é muito importante e foram
importantes a ao escolher a área
científica a como tenho picado eu sou o
geneticista do populações humanas
portanto Já passei a cerca de duas
décadas debruçada a estudar o livro da
vida o livro não uma enciclopédia porque
é enorme Portanto o Genoma Humano o que
é que vocês sabem o h n constituído por
quatro Asus daquela linguagem muito
simples a ser GT
nós temos é cerca de 3,2 mil milhões
dessas letras em duas cópias uma cópia
da mãe outra cópia do pai e só para
vocês terem uma ideia da grandeza do que
isto é já ouvi várias pessoas que
imprimiram estas 3,2 mil milhões de
letras e o tamanho é pesa cerca de 450
kg ocupa cerca de 272 mil páginas e se
tivéssemos dado de datilografar esta
enciclopédia da vida cerca de oito horas
por dia demoraríamos mais de 50 anos a
escrever lá tanta vocês terem uma ideia
da grandiosidade da enciclopédia que nós
com temos em todas as nossas células
humanas e altamente compactada portanto
quando me desafiaram para falar do
infinito para mim uns nome ao infinito
porque a esta quantidade gigantesca
o possibilidades portanto temos 3,2 mil
milhões destas quatro bases não é elas
podem variar aquele que nós conhecemos
por mutação e variante portanto em cada
uma destas posições podemos ter uma das
quatro bases Imaginem a infinitude de
variantes que podem ser gerados na nossa
Genoma humana para além disso a natureza
é muito imaginativa ainda gerou mais uma
uma nova maneira de misturar e criado em
cidade que é a nas nossas células
sexuais no parte dos nomes que veio da
meia parte do meio do pai pode trocar
mensagens entre elas e parte do
cromossoma e Então imagina é como se
trocássemos uma página do guerreiro paz
com uma página do Carolina e temos a
misturar histórias tantas tem mais uma
possibilidade de fazer diversidade tanto
nós temos estas posições todas no nosso
Genoma mas em média Dois seres
e não diferenciam-se mais do que tem
cinco milhões de posições portanto em
média Dois seres humanos não se
diferenciam mais do que deram um era um
por cento do seu Genoma e já vem toda a
diversidade que a gerada não é portanto
é uma infinitude pode ser humano é um
novo ser humano diferente porque Há uma
possibilidade enorme Infinita da geral a
diversidade na nossa espécie e a nossa
espécie então é muito muito recente e
temos as ter ideia também o Genoma é a
molécula que perpetua a informação e da
ao longo das várias gerações portanto
também é uma outra infinidade em nível
temporal então eu estávamos a dizer que
só temos em média cinco milhões 5 mil
milhões de diferenças no nosso enorme
lado de Genoma e isto porque como
espécie nós somos uma espécie muito
recente
é só temos cerca de 300 mil anos o que
numa escala da vida não é é muito muito
recente e curiosamente a maior parte da
diversidade contida na nossa espécie
está centrada então nas populações
africanas como vem ali naquela árvore da
diversidade humana não é toda a
diversidade contida nas populações
europeias e asiáticas representadas ali
azul são uma pequena quantidade da
informação e diversidade genética que
está contida nas populações africanas
isto porco como espécie surgimos no
continente africano e lá permaneceremos
cerca de dois terços da nossa evolução
só a cerca de 70 mil anos atrás é que
ocorreu a primeira migração bem-sucedida
para fora da África um pequeno número de
Africanos da costa leste saiu fez esta
imigra
e esse pequeno número de ancestrais fui
suficiente para estar na origem de todas
as populações que habitam hoje a Europa
EA Ásia Então por mais de dois terços da
nossa vida ficamos restritos ao
continente Africano e toda a outra era a
ocupação do resto do mundo foi ocorreu a
menos de 70 mil anos atrás e eu vos
contar esta história porque aqui ligando
o nome à esta história é mais
informativo mais fácil de entender e
esta é uma história muito muito
interessante antes Jonathan era o
indivíduo nascido em 1784 numa das ilhas
das Caraíbas que era uma colónia
dinamarquesa a sua mãe era uma senhora
escravizada da África que tinha sido
deslocada para as igrejas nas Caraíbas o
seu pai era um dinamarquês que
trabalhava na contabilidade
a Dilma a plantação e quando Jonathan
mudou-se para em 1789 para a Dinamarca
foi com a sua família conseguiu
educar-se mas depois regras mudaram e
como ele era na escrava sua mãe tinha
sido escrava e ele ia ter que ser
transportado novamente para as Caraíbas
e ser escravizados novo então aí ele ter
oportunidade fugir e fugiu para a
Islândia Islândia uma Sora muito remoto
o população muito pequena não é era o
primeiro mestiço a chegar Island
Tailândia permaneceu sempre muito
isolada a poucos africanos que foram
para a Joana não é só muito recentemente
no século 20 então este prometeu-nos
fazer um estudo com a operação com a
empresa de incômodo da da da Islândia E
aí
e foi este senhor teve já identificados
na Islândia cerca de 700 descendentes
189 deles ainda estão vivos então nós
fomos estudar o Genoma destes
ascendentes do ano Jonathan identificar
tudo profissões do seu Genoma tem a
origem da mãe do ano Jonathan não é o
ano Jonathan tinha metal seus nomes de
origem africana e nos seus descendentes
fomos a identificar os pedacinhos que
tinham sido e tardes dele então
estudante todos estes indivíduos e aqui
tá identificados pedacinhos africanos
Azul ok ao longo da transmissão os
recadinhos vão diminuir de geração para
geração Mas agora nós vindo do presente
ir constituído o passado vamos conseguir
juntar toda a informação e juntar tipo
um passou todos os bocadinhos da
sustentabilidade africana do anjo do
natal e foi isto e do que isto é a
menstruação para o cromossomo
é Mas conseguimos então juntar todos os
cromossomas do Genoma os 23 pares e
reconstituir cerca de Trinta e Oito por
cento da metade africana que constituem
o ar Jonathan Total a ver em Jonathan
morreu há muito tempo atrás não sabemos
onde ele está internado não temos
nenhuma amostra biológica dele mas
estudando todos os seus descendentes não
é e os seus nome conseguimos manter
preservar uma memória do que foi o ano
Jonathan e da sua metal avanço
centralidade africana
bom então eu estou-vos a contar uma
história estudando pessoas vivas no
presente conseguimos reconstituir o
passado e só pode aplicar a pessoas que
foram bem-sucedidas têm descendentes
mesmo mesmo pessoas que não tiveram
descendentes ou mesmo espécies que se
consideram extintas conseguimos hoje em
dia reconstituir estudar seu Genoma
então indivíduos por exemplo neandertais
não é como espécies extinguiu a cerca de
20 mil anos atrás conseguimos obter os
seus nomes e mas curiosamente quando
estudamos os nomes Band Pablo foi o
investigador essencial para estudar
então o DNA antigo nestes nos meus da
Thais uma uma coisa muito interessante
foi quando comparamos os nomes do meio
da artal com os nossos nomes Vimos que
nós temos um bocadinho três por cento de
Genoma neandertal europeus e asiáticos
os africanos na opinião de Tais não
existiram no campo
e portanto mesmo espécies que se
consideram extintas não é hoje em dia A
genética consegue estudá-las e dizermos
alguma coisa sobre elas Estes são outros
exemplos de introduções que não temos
tido ao longo do tempo no nosso Genoma
portanto a nossa espécie sempre gostou
se misturar miscigenar Esta é uma
história comum a nós e portanto agora
está ideia do que estudando genomas
somos quase trazemos quase uma nova
arqueologia podemos ir escavando os
nossos nomes identificar sinais de
outras espécies que se cruzaram conosco
outros indivíduos que se conseguiram
prezar conosco e curiosamente a
trouxemos aqui este exemplos este
esqueleto muito completo de um senhor
que morreu há dez mil anos atrás a
enxada é Inglaterra estudando o seu
Genoma conseguimos dizer certas
características dele então Conseguimos
ver que ele tinha
e hoje mas curiosamente é a pele tem uma
tonalidade ainda muito escura até
portanto estudando hoje nome de calçados
de indivíduos que viveram dois mil anos
atrás eram os possível identificar então
que características para o aspecto que
essas pessoas poderiam ter portanto não
é de estranhar que é um mês que tenha
declarado não é que nós somos patrimônio
genético da uma Patrimônio da Humanidade
não é em 1997 o Genoma Humano foi
declarado patrimônio porque conserva-se
a memória do que é a humanidade e como
tal deve ser preservado e esta história
que queria compartilhar com vocês muito
obrigada a